the safe use of
pesticides pesticides are substances
used to prevent control or destroy pests
such as insects weeds and crop rated
diseases without the use of these
substances crops remain highly
vulnerable and unprotected resulting in
limited development and
growth if not used correctly pesticides
can cause more harm than good it's
crucial to always take precautions
before during and after the application
of a
pesticide
labels make sure to always read the
label before you use a
pesticide look out for the hazard
symbols and
warnings these symbols will tell you if
a pesticide is poisonous corrosive
flammable or
explosive the Border shape is also
important the more sides a border has
the greater the
danger health
risks if you come into contact with
pesticides in any way always contact a
poison control expert or
doctor here are some things to remember
when an incident
occurs if a pesticide is swallowed call
a poison control expert or doctor
immediately for treatment advice do not
induce vomiting and do not give any
liquids or food to the person
affected if it gets in your skin or eyes
rinse immediately with water for 15 to
minutes if inhaled move the person to
fresh air if they are not breathing then
give them artificial
respiration but ensure to avoid any risk
of
contamination
environment pesticides are also harmful
to the environment and can easily cause
harm to livestock and habitat lands
when using a pesticide Outdoors always
use buffer zones these are areas that
are left untreated to protect sensitive
areas protective
clothing you should always be fully
covered when using
pesticides remember all clothing and
gear used for spraying must be washed
separately from other
clothing pesticide
application
always test the application rate of new
equipment under typical operating
conditions to ensure it is working
properly when using pesticides Outdoors
remember to monitor site conditions post
buffer zones and create an emergency
response
[Music]
plan
spills be prepared for spills by having
protect of clothing absorbent material a
broom and shovel and a container
available always Mark waste
containers damaged
containers you should routinely inspect
your
containers if you need to replace one
move the pesticide to a container made
of similar material and always label the
replacement
disposal when disposing of pesticides
remember the three Rs rinse remove and
return rinse empty containers repeatedly
and pour into your spray
tank remove cap and paper
label and return clean pesticide
containers for
recycling pesticide
records always keep current records of
your pesticide use including the type
location duration and all other relevant
information this information can be very
[Music]
useful